the coach of the Michigan State Spartans
basketball program fresh off of the big
win in Ann Arbor Tom Izzo back on the
program
how are you coach man I know that had to
be you probably didn't eat when you got
home wiped when cod kids wouldn't do
anything but it was a big win for us and
as you know Michigan's got a very good
team I do but you won't be impressed
with this rich John and I talked about
before the game I mean it's not many
times that two programs in the same
state i ranked I mean Duke Carolina does
it sometimes a little don't Kentucky but
I think Michigan Michigan State now two
teams ranked in the top ten in it it
really was a great first half I mean
3937 it was a lot of points scored a
second has got a little crazier but big
went for us I know you're not you can't
be happy if you be honest but I know I'm
respectful of my of my opponent my rival
opponent respectful I know that I know
that and you're a little gleeful cuz you
got the you got the North the northern
Michigan in you and you're like it's
close to Mario G's ever and he would he
texted me and took him literally five
seconds to text me it's okay no but you
got this kid Cassius Winston man he is
he is so special and you made him a
captain this week which you don't
ordinarily do you did it yourself with
obviously Joshua Langford down for the
season what what caused you to do that
in this week coach that was one thing
and then we lost warden and Cassius
could have been a captain I mean you
know the players vote and wasn't oh you
didn't get voted by him adjust that
judges is loved by everyone but maybe
not as a word as some guys you know
maybe in that respect but when when Nick
Ward went down to I just said to myself
you know Cassius already disclosed the
points and makes the assists and coaches
the team and makes the popcorn why
shouldn't he be captain to and I
we really needed that I think it will
help him I think it will help us so I
did something I haven't done and I I
think he he responded at least he played
very well he really did but I'm gonna
tell you you know your your guys got a
good team it was they didn't shoot as
well as they'd been shooting till the
very end and you know they actually took
some things aware that we do well they
re bonus to first half we got him little
back the second half I think the major
thing for us rich we're kind of a high
turnover team they're one of the lowest
in the country and in this game they
only had six I think they had eight or
nine and I thought that was one of the
big keys to the game now is it true the
last time you did named the captain
yourself was involved draymond Green
no.9 that's what I'm reading about this
last I think that was to be honest with
ya he was but you know some years we
voted some years we didn't we voted the
last five or six years mean some years
we voted the coaches and the players
some years it was just the players and
there's one or two years where I just
appointed him and I think that was the
last time and he's a little different
personality than personalities but they
both helped me win a lot of games not
bad so what did you see it certainly
looked like you were switching out on
that three-point arc quite a bit
defensively what did you see in Michigan
that you thought you needed something I
think John set it up to the game he said
the next time we play them they have a
week off between us knowing Johnny oh
that's seven
thousand new plays and probably
coverages so you know it's gonna be a
little tougher deal when we get them in
our place so do something nice
what is your relationship with beeline
let's dig into that a little bit coach
what do you got for me honestly I have a
good relationship but it bothers all the
people both on our side and here's I
think that I was Michigan well you know
you hate Michigan State it doesn't don't
respect us
it's just what a rivalry is you know you
can't love your rival and but I do
respect my rival and I have very respect
for Johnny's you know I think that the
coolest part of this to be serious for
once is you get to programs in the top
ten that have not the right way to know
there's no I mean he's a by-the-book guy
and I think I am too and and for that I
hope the people in this state appreciate
what's been accomplished it's not like
we're all getting the top recruits in
the country every year but players get
better in our programs and so I think we
personalities are a little different
similarities are pretty much the same
and even went ahead and bought a place
up on a lake in northern Michigan I
think he's trying to be a euchre
Michigan State head coach Tom Izzo
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
I'd love to get your take on the Zion
Williamson conversation that's been
going on nationally since this shoe
exploded during the Duke UNC game that
he shouldn't play anymore there's some
who think that there's too much money on
the line and the young man might
actually do what a lot of college
football players have been doing lately
of note saving themselves for the draft
well what do you think of when you hear
that well the dry sense of humor said to
me said good don't play give somebody
else a chance to win a championship this
year because they're pretty good but the
real side of me says are you crazy I
mean this thing is getting insane you
know I thought Charles Barkley I don't
know as welcome hurt him but he was on
the other day and he was appalled by the
whole thing
you know I mean I don't I don't walk off
out of the door and think I'm gonna get
hit by a car you know it could happen I
don't live every day worried about dying
it could happen I realize in football
there's some more injuries that are
normal but I think if you don't become
just we live your life for money I'm not
sure you'd have a very happy life either
I still remember when magic came back
here when I was a GA he still lived in
Lansing in the summer and he played
every day here you know he played games
I mean those are the craziest games you
could play you know and and then they're
blaming this you you know I was it was a
problem you know we were the same shoes
we haven't had a problem ever you know I
mean some of these things are just media
driven in fact you're the media but I
can tell you would be one of those that
would drive that no I said coach I said
that we don't know what he's saying and
a lot of people are filling the void
with whatever they think he should be
saying were thinking and I said he
should play still because you only get
one yeah you only get one shot at
playing for Duke or playing in college
basketball and but then again like I
said it's not my money
that said though Berkeley did say as you
point out his he said players play he
played for many years you know if that's
what he said you know you know what rich
you know that the funny part is and and
you know much really well but there's
not a pie my dad didn't just yesterday
of course I'm going home but there's not
a time that we get together and the
first thing we go to we both made pretty
good money we both had our own same in
some ways that has been pretty good like
you but the first thing we talk about is
one to be great to go back to college or
we get to know it in for something and
let's go over the trailer park and visit
where we live for three years Oh God and
I think some of these kids are missing
out on some of the greatest times and I
understand why I understand the whole
deal but you know for a lot of them it
doesn't work out and you know this kid
it's going to work out but he if he
wasn't playing in a game he
be working out and he could come to the
same jump stop and the same thing happen
I mean I just don't believe you live
your life that way easy for me to say
because I don't have a son you know
that's that good I'm trying to to ever
marry a girl that's that good and she
makes some money but it ain't happening
right now you know but I really I just
wouldn't want to live my life that way
were you guys in on Zion recruiting him
coach no no I don't think miss Keane was
I think you know um was like you and
some others your penis good enough very
good player but I'm kind of a little bit
of both our you know our norm all right
before I let you go coach Tom Izzo as
always whenever you are on the show I
reach out to Mariucci I'm like anything
I should ask anything you think I should
ask he actually gave me some things okay
you ready for them this is great first
one up there's four of them first one up
why does he play the accordion and he
only knows like two Christmas songs up
on the housetop and something else who
does that that's true the other one I
got down who does that a guy that plays
the accordion once a year is crazy radio
show that I do you know once a week and
I have my team come in and saying I'm
I'm trying to get into the Christmas
spirit you know a lot of times around
here people think I'm Scrooge mm-hmm and
I'm not so I'm trying to get into the
Christmas spirit and it all started with
me and Mariucci because we couldn't get
dates having to go to the Christmas
dinner when we worked at northern
Michigan and everybody brought a date
I brought him he sat on my shoulder I
played the accordion he collected the
money and that's what we survived are
you on my shoulder is that weird what I
mean
telling that he did nothing but sit
there and I at least played the
accordion alright here's another one
he's to call years ago his mom is now 92
I think it Dorothy still goes to some
games is that true yes he was just here
for the last two games before we went
down our verse he was here for a week
and my son's a senior in high school and
she went to one of his games and then
she she went to my 92 doing strong stuff
wives that's awesome yeah and then the
other one he said that your son Steven
it's gonna be a Spartan next year that
it that's is he coming to Michigan State
yeah he's gonna come here and who knows
you know just be around his dad as I
said it's gonna be my chance to make up
for a lot of lost time that you don't
get that that's a muchas godson so I'm
hoping needs to be in the bill okay so
that leads me to my last one which kind
of brings us all full circle in this
entire conversation tom is aware you say
you have respect for your in-state rival
here's the last one
he is the godfather to my daughter
Brielle when she got accepted to
Michigan it took me a month to figure
out how I would break the news is that
true you know cuz these dad actually
went to Michigan State if he can believe
that he told it to me sheepishly and
then I think he talked her out of it she
went to Boston cotton education turns
people into you know we were up six when
I said go get him that's what I thought
but it's only though we play them again
I mean that's not you know you blame
twice within like 13 days but but I
think it kind of talks about the rivalry
you know dimpling kentucky ER I mean
Duke and Carolina are doing the same
thing so maybe
maybe if we both can last a few years
we'll start something here that will
carry on so when your son goes to
Michigan State someday I know he'll have
the pajamas I know that hey coach
thanks for calling in Congrats on the on
the way and congrats on the win there's
Tom Izzo
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience